one of my favorite movies growing up was
the original mighty ducks now i don't
know if that's because i'm canadian and
it's required by law to like anything
hockey related or if i just like the
idea of being a kid and hopping into
strangers limousine but when i heard
disney plus was releasing a
10 episode series i was skeptical after
all the franchise spawned
three mega hit movies and even a one
season animated series
but when i started watching mighty ducks
game changers i was
pleasantly surprised this show is
actually pretty good so my inner
nostalgia got the best of me and i
decided to go back and re-watch the
original mighty ducks and see
just how different or similar these two
versions are
and let me tell you the show does a
great way of staying true to the
original while also
inventing new and fun ways to update the
franchise but before we begin make sure
to slap shot that like and subscribe
button
seriously only eight percent of you are
subscribed so that i can continue
watching movies of my childhood while
holding on to my last remaining
serotonin one of the biggest
game-changing events of the show and yes
the puns will get worse is that we don't
follow the mighty ducks at all in fact
this series takes place almost
30 years after the events of the
original and things
have changed for the worse in those 30
years the ducks have transformed from a
ragtag group of kids playing for the
love of the game
to a machine-like squadron built with
the sole purpose of winning
the kids on the team have personal
trainers follow strict diets and are
punished for losing
in essence the ducks in 2021 are like
how the hawks were
in 1992. it's a great role reversal that
sets up much of the conflict this season
the hawks even have an overbearing coach
named mr t
pity the fool no not that mr t he fills
the role of the must win at all costs
coach
both the movie and series are set in
minnesota following the 12 to 14 year
old district 5 hockey team's quest for
the championship
in the original coach bombay is forced
to coach a team as part of community
service for getting a dui
yeah that's something i totally missed
when i was 10 years old and what better
idea is there than getting a guy who got
a dui to coach your children
coach bombay does play a major role in
game changers but we'll get to him in a
bit
just like the original ducks were a
group of ragtag kids so too are the
don't bothers and yes that's the name of
the main team we follow named after a
line our main character's mother says in
a viral video of her chastising the
ducks for focusing only on winning for
her the ducks have sucked the fun out of
the game so she along with her son
evan who is kicked off the ducks decide
to start their own club in fact the
first episode is a lot like the first
act of the mighty ducks where they have
to go around recruiting members for the
team
the show could have gone the easy route
and recycled a lot of the tropes from
the original like recruiting the guy
who's good at slap shots or the figure
skater who can do some cool moves
but they don't opting to try new things
like the canadian student who ironically
doesn't know how to skate or the female
cosplayer who takes out her fury on the
ice
and even the characters who do resemble
their originals are given more fleshed
out backgrounds like kubler here the
goalie who resembles goldberg who has
parents who never see his games thus he
escapes reality by burying his head in
his phone all day when you have 10
episodes you can really learn and care
more about these characters so that when
the games do happen the stakes are much
higher
so alex morrow the mom from parenthood
and gilmore girls becomes the coach of
this new team but has to find a home
rink
enter the ice palace which was given to
coach bombay by hans and his will
you might remember hans from the
original as that old skate shop owner
and things have
definitely changed for coach bombay 30
years later and he absolutely hates
hockey
here's the long and short of it i hate
hockey and i don't like kids
he even has a sign that reads no hockey
how bombay went from beloved coach to
cantankerous old man is one of the
season's big mysteries
we'll later find out that his pro hockey
career which we see him leave for at the
end of mighty ducks
was cut short when he got an injury he
then went to coach collegiate hockey but
was fired after breaking the recruitment
rules by giving a poor kid money to
afford a stick
not quite sure how that works but c'est
la vie i
spent my entire life
chasing hockey and i have absolutely
nothing to show for it
so part of bombay's arc this season is
much like his original arc in mighty
ducks a dude who doesn't want a coach
learns to rekindle his love for the game
and become
loved by all in the process with it
being decades since the original game
changers
incorporates more tech almost all the
kids have cell phones and they're even
used as one of bombay's
unique practice exercises in the
original the kids use eggs to practice
their passing but in the show
it's their phones that's real ballsy for
a kid's movie mighty duck says no scenes
that take place at school but
game changers changes that all the kids
go to the same district 5 school where
their mascot is the frost
like the movie game changers keeps the
original district 5 teams
in hans's shop you can see a board in
the back that highlights them
this time we get full-on introductions
set with pyrotechnics and lighting and
i'm like this is sure hella different
than when i was playing hockey
it's here at the end of episode 1 that
the don't bothers announce themselves as
an official team
and just like the ducks the don't
bothers have literally no money and
their equipment is random stuff they've
been able to scrounge whereas the
original ducks get their equipment
donated to them by a generous grant from
mr ducksworth the lawyer boss of bombay
who the ducks are named after
the don't bothers break into the lost
and found at the ducks arena fun fact
alex
works at the same law firm that coach
bombay did with 10 episodes there's also
a lot more room to delve into the family
lives of our players with the exception
of charlie's mom in the 1992 version
there are almost no other parents seen
in the original in game changers not
only do we get a wide array of parents
but also different
family situations nick for example has
two gay parents
logan's parents are going through a
divorce and sophies are completely
overbearing i highly doubt that some of
the issues the show tackles would ever
have been addressed back in 92.
so with the team having their own rink
and equipment their first match is
against the cardinals in the original
the duck's first match is against the
hawks they end up losing 12-0
instead of 17-0 like the ducks did back
in 92.
the don't bother second game is against
the ducks and here they
actually lose 17-1 their only goal being
a new play that coach bombay
secretly wrote in alex's playbook in the
original coach bombay created the flying
v which they used to ultimately win
against the hawks this season introduces
us to
new and even more creative plays such as
the breakaway which involves shooting a
player into a group of others like a
bowling pin
and the double helix where players loop
around each other like a strand of dna
like the original game changer's main
kid has divorced parents with a dad who
is barely around
this allows for bombay to swoop in and
become this father-like figure for him
unlike the original bombay
doesn't end up kissing the mom however
there is some unresolved romantic
tension between the two which will
undoubtedly be explored in season 2. now
one of my favorite episodes this season
is where they bring back
actual members from the original trilogy
to inspire the new team
bombay's car window is smashed by fulton
just like it was in the original the old
ducks are back in town to attend the
duck's gala
gala bombay isn't invited to these
members include avermen
fulton connie guy and adam banks from
the original
and ken wu from d2 and d3 now you might
be asking yourself
where's charlie the main character from
all three mighty ducks films
played by joshua jackson well because of
coven and jackson having a baby it made
it impractical to have him appear
writer steven brill said that when they
do bring him back they want it to be
substantial
there's a lot of story to mind between
his relationship with bombay his absence
in the show is explained to bombay that
charlie didn't want to see a coach that
abandoned them initially brill wanted
all the old characters to have recurring
roles in the series like having avermen
be a teacher at the school
but kovit just made it too difficult
this is something that could be explored
in future seasons
speaking of averman he's now a limo
driver with a great callback to the
original as he drives the gang onto the
ice
the old ducks have a practice session
with the new ducks really linking the
two shows together
ironically enough the don't bothers get
their first win against the team that
was the strongest in the original the
hawks
this alongside their meeting with the
old ducks give them the boost they need
to continue their winning streak and
make it to the state finals bombay fakes
a power outage forcing the kids to play
classic pond hockey just like where he
met the original ducks and although the
kids have a love for the game
game changers adds romance between some
of the players
not seen in the original evan has a
crush on sophie and nick on geeky sports
announcer mary jo
unlike the mighty ducks game changers
builds up to the state championships
whereas the original was just for the
district this build-up is all for naught
when they don't bothers have to forfeit
because one of their players suffers an
injury and they need at least
10 players to play and with the ducks
winning out of a technicality the don't
bothers offer them a high-stakes game
on their own ice if they win they get to
take back the name
mighty ducks if they lose they have to
disband the team
forever and coach t is willing to play
dirty to win
not dirty it's hockey
just like coach riley was in the mighty
ducks i want you to drop banks like a
bad habit
i want it out of the game the don't
bothers end up playing with the original
ducks jerseys and win
using the famous flying v play to score
the game-winning goal the mighty duck's
name is officially in the hands of those
who stand for the spirit of the ducks
putting fun camaraderie and teamwork
ahead of winning at all costs now coach
bombay
doesn't get a kiss at the end of this
one but that's probably coming in season
2.
speaking of which there is no word yet
if the show has been renewed but with
the final shot being the ice palace
donning the mighty duck's name i sure
hope disney gives the second season
a shot yep that was another pun thanks
for watching everyone please make sure
to like and subscribe it really helps
the channel out and let me know what you
thought about mighty ducks game changers
for more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at think story yt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much